e
e e
to we will start uh start our day um and
I wanted to welcome we have several uh
substitutes um we have um Lisa Maser
substituting for representative Morris
um we have van representative Vanessa
Sheen substituting for uh representative
dry and representative Edgar uh
substituting for um representative selig
so uh welcome all uh I hope you enjoy
your time in education policy we have a
lot of fun
here um so uh let's start out with the
pledge if we
might L would you lead us thank you I
pledge ALG to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you very much um we have a number
of bills to exact to vote on this
morning um and we'll get uh started
right away with
um
um how about uh HB 662
[Music]
um um you can take the G which is
requiring the discussion of abortion
procedures and viewing of certain videos
during health education in public
schools
um open the executive session on HB 662
and I recognize representative cord for
a motion uh I would move itl on House
Bill 662 is there a second I'll
second representative Freeman
representative cordelli discussion yes
thank you um I think that this um bill
um goes a little bit too far in terms of
uh naming specific uh videos um
requiring that that uh two out of the
three named videos be shown uh each year
in high
school um I think that's a little bit
much um I don't have a problem with
showing um uh videos um on abortion
itself but uh naming specific videos and
requiring each year each year in high
school I think goes too far uh plus um
the fact that uh it gets the Attorney
General's office uh involved in um
monitoring um the uh viewing and
possibly uh Prosecuting um if videos
aren't shown um I think I would hope
maybe the Attorney General's office has
some better things to do um with their
time so for that reason uh I move uh
itl any discussion from the
second no thank you madam chair I would
um I would absolutely a th% agree with
representative cordelli on why this bill
should be ited um while I I do
appreciate the sentiment of it I think
there's just too many too many Hoops to
jump through and too many hurdles and um
the meaning of the bill would definitely
be get lost with some of the minutia so
I agree with representative Celli right
and and I appreciate the 1,00% agree
with me thank you it's not gonna happen
again any other discussion
representative wock thank you madam
chair i' just like to comment on the
bill as well I'm appreciate the fact
that I believe our health and wellness
teachers uh in our Public Schools do a
hell of a job and we don't need to
legislate from here what particular
curriculum they use thank
you any other
discussion seeing none Madam
clerk start Vice chair and you last
um May I just clarify representative is
it
Missour
merer thought I did so good okay all
right um so this is on Bill number 662
the motion is itl representative Noble
yes representative Terry yes
representative Sheen yes representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield is
yes representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Maser yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
Edgar I representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes
okay 18 to
zero uh consent no objections
great thank
you
do I have a g do you want to go
to um HCR 6
yep uh we're going to open the executive
session on HCR
6 and I rep uh recognize representative
cordelli for a motion
uh thank you very much this is HCR 6
which was the uh removal super uh
resolution for removal of the
superintendent of uh District
right and uh I would move uh itl on uh
HCR uh six is there a second
representative Paul
seconds any discussion from the maker of
the
motion uh thank you very much um I'm
just looking for the bill but um yeah I
I understand the sentiment um of the uh
Prime sponsor um in this case um that uh
uh involved no trespass orders um being
handed out to several parents at a girls
uh soccer game um in which they were
wearing uh Pink uh wristbands with XX on
them to uh show their support for uh
girl
Sports
um this case um is in the courts right
now um I I think it would be um
in my opinion bad precedent to for us to
start um calling for the removal of um
uh Educators who we don't um agree with
on a certain um incident or um subject
area um so I I think that uh we're
better off uh iing this and uh leaving
it to the courts
any discussion from the
second thank you thank you and um yeah I
I can't say that I understand the
sentiment as much as you do but um I
think that was an inappropriate
resolution it targeted an individual
it's in the courts um I'm glad that
we're taken care of it now because I
think we've drawn it out long enough and
um itl is clearly the appropriate motion
for this any other
discussion seeing none Madam
cler so the motion is itl on HCR
6 representative
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative Sheen yes representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Maser yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative baloni yes representative
Edgar I representative kuger yes and
representative Snodgrass yes 18 to
zero I think I can hand the gabble back
now thank you very much do we clarify
consens yes yes consent
yeah uh so uh next we will take
up um
hr9 which is urging the Department of
Education to emphasize stem
education and I call on representative
Freeman for a motion thank you Mr chair
Mr chair I would make the motion of
ought to
pass thank you is there
representa
Terry uh representative Freeman would
you like to speak to your motion uh
briefly um while you know house
resolutions don't carry as much weight
as an A bill would um I do think
that this would send a very clear
message to everyone that we are really
looking forward um instead of backwards
when it comes to the education of our
children I really think this is probably
one of the most nonpartisan house
resolution will ever see we all agree
that going forward in the 21st century
this is one of the emphasis we need on
education so um with that I would ask
everyone on this committee to support
the aop
pass uh thank you further discussion
representa Terry did you want to comment
I just want to add that having uh family
members who are involved in uh teaching
uh stem courses in uh in another state
uh the name of which I will not uh
mention here um for um obvious reasons
uh very very supportive of stem and uh
so I'm I'm really delighted to see this
resolution uh I think it's uh it's very
timely
uh yes representative Cornell I I just
want to say I think the students that
testified at the hearing were were
wonderful in in putting their um case
across of why it's so important to have
stem education and I just wish it could
be steam so that we could add the Arts
into it too but that's a Bild further
down the line I think but they were
coming from a school that emphasizes
stem so I could see that but it would be
nice to do steam to it I think it's
great represent Woodcock thank you want
be repetitive actually represent Cornell
and and per caught my attention uh
almost exactly the same was it was
amazing to see those youngsters come
particularly in that big Hall represent
of cordelli uh not knowing what was
going to happen they did a heck of a job
I also have a family member who's
involved in Steam it runs a steam
festival in San Diego annually and I'll
be visiting it next week
great enjoy San Diego and some warmer
weather uh any further discussion on
this
bill seen none Madam clerk whenever
you're ready thank you this vote is on
house resolution 9 ought to pass yes
representative
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative Sheen yes representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield is
yes representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
merer yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray enthusiastically
yes representative Woodcock absolutely
representative representative Hall yes
representative baloni yes
representative Edgar I representative
kuger yes and representative Snodgrass
yes so oh excuse me and chairman
cordelli thank you
yes consent chairman yes that's 18 to
zero yes sir uh consent okay yep great
thank
you uh next we will take up uh House
Bill 440 relative to education educ
educator licensing and representative
Freeman did you have a motion for this
Bill thank you Mr chair I do have a
motion I have a motion of ought to
pass thank you is there a
second representative
Terry uh representative Freeman did you
want to comment on your motion thank you
thank you Mr chair briefly um uh uh
I do believe that this is a pivotal um
bill for us at this we we're really
experiencing a shortage of Career and
Technical
instructors and um seeing as the CTE
instructors don't teach any Core
Curriculum um but instruct on um their
career or technical path I I do believe
this would address some of the shortages
we're seeing in the CTE programs and um
and and really allow all our students an
opportunity to receive a career path
that they may have
chosen okay
um um we'll hold off from a moment um we
had a motion and a second correct yes
sir on that of ought to pass yes sir um
I understand there is um an
amendment um that uh representative Hall
is getting and uh will'll pass out
oh yeah oh
good
Jim this is a
different okay so
um yes of course
yes uh does anyone need a a copy of uh
the amendment to HB
440 everyone have a
copy um representative
Hall okay y um representative Hall could
you uh introduce your
Amendment yes thank you Mr chair uh I'd
like to introduce Amendment um
0188 um to 440 and the only change on
this is adding the word initial on line
six so that it's clear that it's just
the initial license thing that we're
talking about and not all of them and we
I think we spoke about this during the
hearing so it's just adding the word
initial on line
six okay um and since we have't ought to
pass motion on the floor um would you
like to make a motion in relation to
your Amendment yes I would thank you uh
if we could do ought to pass as amended
um for 440 uh
01888 okay um
yeah have to V on the am am
so pass on the amendment
right just have to have the motion in
the amendment then we do ought to pass
as
amended we don't vote
right yeah we vote on the amendment yes
yeah right yeah I'm sorry yeah
misunderstood
sorry is there anyone else who would
like to
comment
um uh represent Paul you moved to pass
on the amendment was there a second
second okay we have second third and
fourths on
that
umse gosh
yes i' forgotten about
it yeah we'll we'll make it um yeah you
can hold that but then
uh okay is there anyone else who would
like to uh comment on Amendment o
188h
just represent Terry ju uh just a
question when otherwise other than an
initial application would somebody be
would would somebody be doing this I'm
trying to understand why in I can
understand initial but I'm trying to
understand why initial how does
that
um limit
those that would have to do
this I guess I'm asking the question
through the chair to the uh maker of the
amendment representative Hall just to
make it clear Mr chair I believe the
renewal process renewal thank you yes
thank
you any further
discussion represent McDonald I have
another question for the offer of the
amendment along the same lines if it
says as determined by the State Board of
Education when it's up for renewal
couldn't the State Board of Education
determine that an assessment's not
necessary then and if they do determine
an assessment's necessary maybe they
have a reason for doing
so am I reading that
correctly oh sorry I'll say that again
um you said that other than the initial
time it may be when the license is up
for Renewal and it says the assessments
determined by the State Board of
Education so couldn't the State Board of
Education decide for whatever reason
they don't need to take the test again
for Renewal and that would be something
determined by them is the statute
allowing for
that thank you well I don't think they
have to take an assessment every time is
that what you think they only take the
assessment to get the initial
certification okay and then my question
is without this amendment without the
word initial couldn't that still be the
case
it now go ahead it could be the case but
this clarifies it so that if I'm
renewing that I don't have to worry
about it was basically a clarification
with uh was it Mr applebe was here
um it was just it was just to make sure
they knew that it was just the first
time you don't have to do deal with this
at all if it's a renewal got it thank
you anyone else oh repr of L
thank you um I I'm trying to pull up the
bill right now but this amendment was
actually suggested to us through
professional
testimony
yeah I've seen no further uh
discussion um Madame clerk when you're
ready we'll uh uh take a vote on uh
Amendment
H okay um
Vice chairman Noble yes representative
Terry yes representative Sheen yes
representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield is
yes representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
merer yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative baloni yes representative
Edgar I represent kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes okay so the
amendment carries 18 to
Z uh representative Freeman would you
like uh to uh uh put forward another
motion um with the passage of the
amendment well I thank you Mr chair I
think I would um I would move to ought
to pass with
Amendment thank you is there a second re
rebs and PA
I do it
again yeah
got did you represent Freeman did you
want to comment while the uh clerk is
getting the paperwork ready uh no thank
you Mr chair I I when my comment
previously still stands thank you any
further comment on
otpa seen none um Madam clerk when
you're ready okay so this is um otpa on
Bill number 440 with Amendment 01
188h Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
Sheen yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield is yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
merer yes representative Nat yes NATO
sorry representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
Edgar I representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes okay so that
carries a to passes amended 18 to zero
consent okay
great uh
let's move on
to uh house
bill
um
222 which is repealing the requirement
for an mou memo of understanding between
a chartered public school and School
District regarding how students with
disabilities are
serviced
um and um uh before we have have a
motion um we did have um a
correspondence last night from um I
think the representative from uh the
Charter School Alliance Miss Adams um I
I did not have a chance to pass that out
to the entire committee um could you um
explain
no or is there someone from the Charter
School Alliance yes
um explain the the clarification that
you wanted to make um to the
committee can you put on the microphone
thank you yeah and yeah I'm sorry yes
yeah some of some of these emails run
together in my memory yes which point
particularly are you referring
to um um was the was there an email
clarifying one point that came up during
the discussion about the um Theus and
um right would somebody else was it
someone else okay I'm sorry I think it
might have came from you that's why I'm
asking I was
like I'm
sorry
um my name is Beth McClure
and I'm the chair of the alliance for
public charter schools um the point I
wanted to clarify is that the the um
overs there's quite a bit of oversight
from the school districts for charter
schools with um students with IEPs they
attend the District representative has
to attend IEP meetings progress meetings
um participate they lead the process in
the I P development and the approval the
charter school has no um vote in that
process they're they're at the table but
the school makes the school district
makes the final decision um they the
charter school also provides service
logs for services that are contracted
with the district and um attendance logs
so there's a lot of oversight much more
than could be accomplished with
anou um the the original intent that I
was told for the M us was to ensure that
there were Services delivered and um I
had never heard anything about oversight
so if that actually was the original
intent there is a lot of
oversight any questions from the
committee great thank you very
much and I apologize to the committee
for not sending that around to everybody
um so with that um representative
McDonald did you have a motion yes I
move a to pass on House Bill
222 okay is there a
second
Bon thank you represent McDonald would
you like to comment yes uh thank you for
the clarification that's much
appreciated and along the same lines of
what was just mentioned there is already
oversight regardless of Theus and the
current um Statute in law that this bill
seeks to repeal has no way to be
enforced and there's not a penalty for
lack of compliance we heard during
testimony that right now 94 of Theseus
are not signed and 16 of them two years
in a row have not been signed so this
law has not really been being followed
but is also a lot of time and effort and
legal fees that go into it and drafting
multiple m a charter school of multiple
districts that they contract with it's
become needlessly burdensome and for
that reason I would hope that we could
pass this Bill thank you
again representative
Bon uh yes thank you um along I think
that uh representative McDonald carried
most of the points that I had brought
forward in my testimony but I would just
say that you know the two groups are
working together uh quite well in trying
to you know prevent and to solve any
issues that arise and any legislation
that comes forward um if there needs to
be further oversight this isn't the way
to do it so and that's it thank
you thank you any further discussion
from committee
members seen none Madame clerk to you
thank you this is House Bill 222 the
motion is a to pass uh Vice chairman
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative Sheen yes representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield is
yes representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Maser yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
Edgar I representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes so that motion
carries 18 to zero consent okay great
um uh there is an amendment to House
Bill uh
699 um that I just passed out um
representative Cornell would you like to
take a brief recess to discuss the
amendment with your your
team yes please great so we'll we'll
take a uh a brief recess
excuse me uh yes a brief caucus
right thank
you
e
e e
and so as as soon as I get confirmation
of that we'll uh take up a couple more
bills
and just for anyone who's here who might
be interested at 1:00 we're going to
have a a work session on three bills
related to
bullying and it's not mandatory
attendance for uh
substitutes
e e
it looks like we're uh
live um In Living
Color on the internet so um we'll move
on to uh a couple of more bills on this
morning uh the first will be House Bill
719 uh repealing the use of unused
um freaking me out if it does my first
question
be so a few committees are live
evidently
um so uh this is unused District
facilities um by charter
schools and uh I call on representative
McDonald for a motion thank you Mr chair
on House Bill 719 FN imve itl
uh do I have a
second I'll second that representative
Freeman uh represent McDonald would you
like to discuss your motion uh yes I
would thank you um 719 it repeals the
right of first refusal to chartered
Public Schools when purchasing or
leasing unused School District buildings
um since enacted in 2022 the Department
of Education to the best of all
knowledge has not received any
complaints from school districts
regarding the right of first refusal and
only one unchartered public school has
leased a building from a school district
since a law was enacted that's what was
said at testimony um so the major so I
think that this really is addressing a
non-existing problem but also has the
potential to impede charter schools and
their expansion chartered Public Schools
I should say um such as the reporting
requirements that would also be repealed
and it would make Charter Schools less
likely to know of available buildings
and if they don't know of an available
building then how can they bid or make
an offer
so I think at this time this bill is
Expediting to legislate so thank you
thank you representative Freeman further
discussion no but thank you Mr chair I I
Echo the sentiments of Representative
McDonald thank you any other committee
discussion on this bill
719 represent Bal Bon uh thank you um I
just want to say that I think there was
some um interesting testimony brought
forward and certainly I I read through a
lot of the uh online support for the
bill emphasizing local controls for
school districts to be able to um handle
their own um real estate in a way that
best suits the community however I would
agree with representa McDonald because
we really don't know we really haven't
seen how it affects so let's let's wait
and see if it does become an issue um I
think that some of the original language
in the in the bill that passed could be
problematic but until we see what
happens I don't think it makes any sense
to do anything with it this this time
thank
you thank you anything
further if not Madam clerk thank you the
motion is itl on House Bill number
719 Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
Sheen yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
merer yes represent NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock
no representative Hall yes
representative Balon
yes representative Edgar hi
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass yes and chairman cordelli yes
okay so this is um 17
to1 uh is consent still okay or would
there be a Minority
Report there will not be a Minority
Report from this minority okay so
consent is all
right thank you thank
you and we'll give the clerk a moment
but uh there's going to be one more Bill
we're going to take up um which is uh on
the uh list for tomorrow but we'll take
take it up
now and that is House Bill
184 related to uh study committee uh
looking into uh changing the school
start
times no
yeah
yeah the calendar
says a 184
um before we uh take up 184 let me uh
check on one thing if I
might
e
e e
so um since um yeah House Bill 184
uh is in the calendar for tomorrow um we
will not take it up
today um so
um yeah um we can um represent Terry
does have an amendment um to that um
that uh we can pass out now so everyone
has a chance to look at it look at it in
advance of tomorrow morning um is it
appropriate to say anything at all or
just distribute it just distribute it
all right
um and um we'll take that up tomorrow
along with the other bills that are on
the
calendar um tomorrow morning and uh so
with that I think that we are done for
the morning and we are back at 1 for um
our work
session
no thank you very much thank you
yeah I figured we couldn't do this today
cuz it's on the calendar for tomorrow
yeah however let me not say anything
that I should not
say thank
you
for
e
e e
yeah it's just it's just a work session
so all right whatever you need
[Music]
must
have make it
work I just looked at and I was
like okay um we we are uh back in
session and we have a work session
actually scheduled for um The Next
Period of time uh dealing with three
bullying
bills HB 108 is relative to bullying and
cyber bullying across multiple school
districts HB 384 is prohibiting bullying
in
schools and 673 is relative to bullying
and discrimination
plans uh I'll just note for everyone's
uh benefit HB 384 is an early
bill so we have to vote It Out by March
6th um but we can continue working on um
the other two bills and um use one of
them as a vehicle uh to try and
accomplish something on the topic um
so um want uh and I'll also mention if
you have your um uh
books um out um this topic really begins
on page 601 RSA
fing aad rush for
the was it something I
said
um yeah I think it might be helpful to
reference um at some point um uh the
current
statute um because it uh does go
into
um
uh everything from um bullying and cyber
bullying to
retaliation and uh training reporting
and the process of uh
investigating uh bullying
incidents um so just as
a um
refresher um
we take a look at
384 um
first um
and the topic starts on page uh
603 um 384
first
um was uh I think the first bill we
heard on the
topic and it is
um quite prescriptive in terms of what
it
requires um including uh conflict
resolution um as part of it and uh one
thing that uh Drew quite a bit of
attention during the uh hearing I
believe was the um requirement for
appointment of a Bine
officer
um we had quite a few people testing
Define and
um it
um I'm not sure how anyone feels about
um talk about um The Bullying officer
first because that um had quite a bit of
attention in the hearing uh does anyone
have any thoughts on appointment of a
bulling
officer if I may Mr chair yes seeing as
um all most middle schools and all high
schools at this point have an RSO
resource school
officer um and I'm not 100% sure what
their responsibilities are but why would
we add another officer if we have an
officer in the schools who may have some
insight or is this is already part of
his responsibilities it just seems
duplicative represent Mar thank you Mr
chair I think to that end also there was
some conversation about whether or not
this would add an additional layer to
the Juvenile Justice
System um so I I I hear uh
representative uh Freeman's Point as
well I I I do I am curious as to whether
or not sro's have the ability to have
that role or potentially play that role
in addition to their already tasked
responsibilities and I think there was
some discussion if I remember about
whether or
not that would be in their
purview so I I don't know if there was
anyone able to speak to that or answer
that question for you um just following
up um when you talked about um
Children's Services um I think maybe
were referring to that the last
paragraph and Chin's right yeah yeah
um further yes ribson of Pa thank you Mr
chair uh did we talk about the resource
officer kind of like being the good guy
in the school and making that person The
Bullying officer maybe I'm making this
up uh The Bullying officer giving a role
that's more
punitive so to speak rather than this
positive
relationship I don't know if we talked
about that or not but in my mind I think
of that resource officer was supposed to
be this liaison between the kids and law
enforcement and whatnot so I don't know
just a thought
right
um yes go ahead uh if I may Mr chair
also I think that we had also heard from
the disability rights um advocacy groups
about whether or not there was adequate
sort of resources or
um representation for individuals with
disabilities if if they were in this
space um if I remember correctly um
there was some concern about whether or
not that could be construed as bullying
and when in fact it was just a part of
their
disability um yeah there there is a a
definition
um on page three three
601 um bullying and uh cyber bullying
definitions
um uh I believe we had we had looked at
that
um uh I'm not sure if it was last term
or the term before um and did not change
I might have been last year last term um
did not change any of the
definitions
um um
but
yeah I think the current
definitions are adequate in my opinion
represent of Cornell I I think the
definition of the bullying officer was
somewhat Vue also um it could be the
resource officer but it also says school
boards and Boards of Trustees have
chartered public schools which I don't
know if they have resource officers in
chared public schools shall appoint
bullying officers for their districts or
Char so does it is it saying that they
can appoint the fette teacher to be the
bullying officer to to do these list of
Duties it doesn't really say who the
Boolean officer is I don't think
no right leaves that open yes
representative halls and I know when uh
Miss Rosenberg spoke from the disability
Center she also was concerned I think
according to my notes Here of of having
people that aren't trained in
evidence-based behavior that that was a
concern of hers um so it should to your
point if I may ask a question of the
representative who made that comment do
you know of any
evidence-based techniques because I I
went looking for evidence-based
techniques on bullying and I wasn't able
to come up with
anything a side oh if it's for me I no I
don't know I'm just looking my
notes
right um does anyone have any opinion on
the um Children's
Services
um and
investigation um and um that's in uh sub
makes me yeah new sub paragraph 3 on
page two
um thank you Mr chair one of the things
I think we had referenced um 69d as the
area that spoke about chins and I think
we heard conversation around it normally
being around truancy runaway
students uh criminal code violations
severe cognitive fire
[Music]
um sure is okay one additional
conversation that in question that I had
actually personally had about whether
like student protection or student
rights and whether or not this a Chin's
petition would open up a situation where
a student would need a guardian at liem
potentially and I think that you know
when we talk about guardian of Liams
they're there on the child's best
interest um so I I do have a lot of
questions about how that process would
work um to ensure that if if they were
going through a Chin's petition that
that a student and or parent um you know
parents can be a part of that process
but oftentimes there are guarding items
awarded by a court to help a child move
through a system
right yeah I personally I don't think we
need to get um that involved with in our
B statutes at this point
representative Bon thank you um I'm just
referencing uh some of the policies that
uh districts already have in place and
the one in particular I'm looking at is
the um jic policy yep um it has actually
a lot of the what is oh in this bill
when you talk about a bullying uh
officer it appears that like in The Jig
policy they talk about the building
administrator being being in charge of
of tracking those complaints and making
sure um that they're followed through so
I I I think that is already covered in
the policies that the school districts
have um and U so I I what I don't know
is uh I think all the school districts
are required to have this policy and um
my question would
be is is this all this necessary um for
what it's trying to accomplish I think
that there are procedures already in
place um
all this do do you mean
um uh specifically the referencing to
the um Chin's program and all that yeah
sorry right
yeah
um is there anything in statute
currently that um
requires naming of someone um um to
U track um bullying
cases um it does have some um language
about
uh principal or
design being involved which I guess um
would be similar to this school
administrator
um how about the requirement in this um
for the
um
um conflict
resolution um aspects um which are on
the first
page um I think some discussion of that
has come up um in with previous
legislation and um that was concerned
about uh um in some cases getting the U
perpetrator
and um alleged victim um involved um
together um whether that's always um a
good policy or
not um
and that's also where um representative
Freeman talks about online 20 evidence
Bas evidence-based
methods
um I don't think there is anything in
current statute um requiring uh conflict
resolution that I recall
so from what I'm
hearing
yes I don't know about putting it into
luck I think each situation is is
sometimes different you know and where
sometimes it might be a good idea to do
conflict resolution and have the the
students sit down and and discuss it and
work it out and other times that
wouldn't be the best solution so you
know and and this also I think the
intent to this was to get parents more
involved in trying to solve it and and
again I think that's something that can
be situational too to try and get the
parents to to come in and talk about it
or to to work with their child about
doing something so and and there are
requirements in statute now about
notification of parents and time frames
for doing
so um
um anyone else have any feelings about
conflict resolution being
required
okay do the students like maybe at the
beginning of the year are they do they
go through anything
about like not bullying like are they
informed about that at
all
go interesting you just asked that
because I was just reading um on page
193f 5 yes if you read that it talks
about the training and actually
evidence-based uh educational programs
which serve supposed to support that
training for anyone working with the
students including volunteers employees
Etc and uh pupils and parents as well
yeah
yeah Marie thank you Mr chair I think
also um most districts at the beginning
of the year provide a school code of
conduct um and those are available
generally online or in person in hard
copy that the students do receive those
at the beginning of the year they're
asked to review them parents are well
aware of what those code of conducts are
as well um so I think there are pro some
procedures in place
around the that if if that's what you
were asking by sure no yeah I think so
um the other thing I just I I did want
to mention with regard to this this and
maybe others is that we want I just want
to make sure that we're being very
careful that um we're talking about
things as like an alleged perpetrator
until the investigation had gone through
I know that this bill specifically says
the word perpetrator first assigning
that maybe they have already committed
the act before
the um actual in investigation or
whatever is complete so they're
allegations until the findings are
done right
okay so just one other thing I was just
came to mind as I was reading through it
um children of different ages would
require much different interventions
dependent upon it and this bill really
doesn't make that differentiation with
what you would do in a case of a an
elementary school student versus a high
school student so I think that's
important to note that
um school districts should have the um
um the option of choosing the Beth inter
intervention method that fits the family
the student and and the school and the
and the building culture
itself thank
you um so what I'm hearing is that um
there the committee doesn't have any
interest in moving anything forward um
to
involve um getting involved with chins
or DCF or anything like that at this
point um and that there is uh concern
about um mandating conflict resolution
in all
cases if I'm summing things up um
correctly representative
Noble there is one piece that I do kind
of like about
this and it's um online 21 participation
of the perpetrator in age appropriate
anti-bullying class or Workshop not that
I'm saying that they need a full class
or Workshop but if they had to watch a a
a video like so that they understand
that
impact um it might be easier for them to
to understand the impact when it's not
somebody that's like talking at them
like when they're in trouble you know
what I mean so I think that this is the
only piece that I think might be
helpful I agree actually with uh
representative Noble in terms of um but
I think that is included in the training
component that that is referenced in the
law that would be what I would say like
you know if you're having workshops or I
know like in in like in Middle School my
town when there were instances of
bullying taking place groups were put
together and kind of taken through steps
and and and given like how would you
feel you know so I I do know that the
the social workers at the um at the
individual schools treat each inance
very seriously and and work through the
student population so I would I would I
would say that it's probably already
included in the law okay
I am also aware of cases however where
the school has not been maybe as
diligent in addressing a bullying case
as
um we think they should be
um and there is
no um real um
teeth in this in terms of the reporting
or parental involvement or anything um
other than um F9 which is a private
right of
action so that you know could be
something else that's you know required
via policy or something
else
um just to consider
um you
want sure that you just brought up has
y has this ever been used do you know
the F9 yeah uh
no um
let's take a look at
um 108 which I think uh is represented
McDonald's
bill
um and I believe representative you also
had a uh an amendment that I I think was
passed out yes during the lunch break I
passed out Amendment 0446 H to House
Bill 108
um and and since this is just a work
session we're just just working off the
proposed amendment is that what we're
we're not obviously no right we're not
okay
yeah just for discussion
okay thank you
um do you want to talk about the bill
and um the amendment yes um during the
hearing for House Bill 108 which I
believe was about a week ago or so there
were some concerns raised um regarding
the bill as presented so the amendment
aims to address those
concerns and it also takes into
consideration some points that were
raised by the New Hampshire school board
Association and so it very minor
changes and the amendment replaces the
bill as
well
um yes representative Hall yes uh
representative can I call him
representative McDonald could you just
explain like what actually changed if I
had to a side by side sure um on the
amendment if you look at line 11 and
onward that's the part that's changed
and I'll just read it to you in cases of
bullying Andor cyber bullying across
multiple school districts the principles
or designes of all districts involved
shall be responsible for conducting an
investigation and are encouraged to
collaborate in such cases the
investigation shall be initiated by the
principal or design of the first
district to learn of the incident my
intention with this is because within
the original Bill I said where the
action originated but if we haven't had
the investigation yet we often don't
know where the action originated so the
point of this is to say all districts
that we believe to be involved should
participate and then the district that's
the first to hear about the incident is
the one to initiate that investigation
so this encourages more collaboration
among the the districts and then I'll
point out that it says principal or
design so if someone in that district is
more fit it really allows for the local
control to determine who is the person
in each district responsible for these
type of
things um just represent thank you Mr
chair uh did we get any Clarity on um
the circumstance in which like
potentially it could be an outof State
party that would participate
in
um a circumstance like in the event of
like potentially cyber bullying or
something like that where it was out of
state did we have guidance like how that
initiation across state lines would
occur or does that have to can that
simply be done by a district on their
own or does that have to involve another
entity to communicate across state lines
to ask for that
collaboration um yeah that was a
question that came up in a prior Bill
also related to cyber bullying um you
know it could be uh someone in uh
California right um right um I'm not
sure if that would be defined as um
cyber bullying or some other
offense
um uh could we have um a lawyer join us
at the table maybe for her
opinion sure mean I I think there was
one sitting in the back
um uh who who works for the
Department yeah
right well we yes we do have another
lawyer in the room
also right
yes and they will always agree it's true
I know I'm married to one so yes a great
time in my house um well good afternoon
good just little closer to you yeah oh
that's right you want me to be louder no
one's ever asked me to do that before um
so Diana Fenton uh an attorney with the
Department of
Education so I'm really appreciative
that this committee is taking up this
issue of
bullying across districts we have had
this case occur um it happened in
profile up north
um I don't
know I don't know the short answer to
your question I think it is an excellent
question and it is just a matter of time
I wasn't really thinking California I
was thinking more along the lines of
Massachusetts um but it doesn't matter
does it because the world is wide open
so I think in that instance it was
challenging enough when you had two
districts having to work together who
was responsible for taking the lead and
I think that what I liked about this
language is that it it specified who was
responsible for the
investigation um because someone has to
take the lead in terms of you know
across state lines that is inherently
challenging and I would assume without
knowing the exact
facts my inclination would be that there
would have to be discussions between the
state agencies that's how I would
initially handle it if that fact pattern
were were brought to my attention which
I think again it's just a matter of time
until that
occurs and my inclination again and this
is all speculation right before we have
an exact fact pattern we don't know how
it's all going to play out but my
inclination would be that the Department
of Education would work with its
counterpart the Massachusetts Department
of Ed and have the department of Ed down
there reach out to the district that's
how I would approach it um initially I
think that if you had a district reach
out to a Massachusetts
District it it it wouldn't be effective
not because they don't want to work
together but that's not your best route
of communication
all thank you Mr chair so so what I hear
you saying is District to District
communication would probably not be the
preferred
like um first set of of communication to
open the lines between two
state if there if there is suspicion
that there has been an offense you know
an offense out of state um to
representative McDonald's point we want
to we want to get to the Genesis of what
happened but there's nothing compelling
that the individual districts to have to
communicate between one another is that
what you're saying I think that's right
okay yeah I and I think I think what you
said is exactly the issue there's
nothing to compel that
cooperation and I can only compare it
analogize it if you will to my prior
work as a criminal prosecutor when we
had crimes or ass supect to go over
state
lines we wouldn't defer to a local
police department to coordinate with the
other local police department that would
be ineffective it's not that they don't
want to work together but you would have
to raise it to that that higher level so
I think when you have two school
districts within the state of New
Hampshire we always defer to local
control and this is a great idea to say
who leads this how does this get
accomplished because you need to have
that direction the school districts need
that direction um but when you have
competing interests going across state
lines that is just a completely
different analysis and I think you
summarized it perfectly there's nothing
in this legislation and as compelling as
this legislation can be it's ineffective
in Massachusetts right it's ineffective
in other in other states um so how does
that get accomplished again my go-to
would be I would refer to the state
agencies I have one more follow sure
okay um so my additional question is
there a possibility after the initial
State agencies are contacted that there
would be other parties contacted between
the states potentially law enforcement
attorney generals something like that
absolutely okay and I don't think it's
outside the realm of possibility to
include the Attorney General's office in
that discussion it's going across state
lines that is a totally different
analysis and I would be foolish to sit
here and say it is not a big deal um
case in point when the Department of
Education wanted
to create anou a memorandum of
understanding it's not a contract it's a
memorandum of understanding police
departments do it all the time
um with the state of Massachusetts to
have the ability to check the
Massachusetts uh central registry before
the Department of Education licens
someone someone to teach that is
a uh Common Sense policy if you will um
to check that registry because we have
so much back and forth traffic between
our two states we all know
that we had to undertake legislation in
order to enter into a memorandum of
understanding we weren't doing a
contract we weren't doing anything that
was binding on either State there was no
financial responsibility from either
State and yet I had to come before this
legislative body and pass a law that
allowed me to then draft a memorandum of
understanding so people ask me why did
that project take you five years well
well let me tell you why it took me five
years because we were going out of state
and because we were going out of state
working with a fellow state agency it
had to go in front of the executive
Council I I thought you were going to
say it took you five years because you
were dealing with the New Hampshire
legislature oh no I would never say that
uh especially since my microphone is is
on but um but I just I I use that to
highlight the point that when you are
going out of state the analysis changes
and it changes
significantly so looking I'm sorry
resident McDonald thank you Mr chair and
thank you attorney
fening to address outof State um
investigations would this bill benefit
from say saying that the district should
contact the New Hampshire doe so that
the New Hampshire doe could contact the
state agency in Massachusetts California
or wherever or would another line
address the
issue I think it could be a a start um
you know and again I I really do applaud
this committee
for thinking that globally of how do we
address these issues that we know are
coming um I think in in my work it's so
easy that we're always kind of behind
the eightball instead of getting out
ahead of it so I really applaud you for
that um maybe it's simple it's as simple
as a line of you know in in cases
of bullying and or cyber bullying across
state
lines the New Hampshire school district
and please don't don't start writing I'm
just spitballing here the New Hampshire
school district um will contact the
Attorney General's office the Attorney
General's office would then refer it to
the Department of Education if it's
appropriate but recognize that these
cases of bullying and cyber bullying can
can very quickly become criminal in some
instances you just don't know what the
fact pattern is going to be so I I would
feel more comfortable uh with having the
Attorney General's office at Le looped
into that and they can certainly and
would refer it to the Department of
Education if they felt it was
appropriate that's really helpful thank
you you're very welcome thank you
Freeman thank you Mr chair thank you for
coming in front of us and and correct me
if I am incorrect but isn't there a
federal agency that deals specifically
with cyber
bullying for some reason in In My Memory
Bank I I do remember hearing about an
agency that deals specifically on the
federal level with cyber bullying
because it's into some of these cases
are into State sure uh there very well
could be
I'm not aware of it off the top of my
head it wouldn't surprise me because
you're right the impact it has is really
quite
breathtaking yes representative litfield
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I just want to make
sure that I'm understanding this
correctly so if we're putting it into
law um that we're going to go to the de
doe if any of The Bullying happens
between State LA between state lines
would that deter some people from
actually going to get help like is it it
just seems to me like it's subjective
like wouldn't we want them to have local
control to decide whether or not they
actually need to get the doe or the AG
involved I feel like I'm missing
something
here I think the issues that have been
raised are just recognizing the
complexities the inherent complexities
that arise
when things go across state
lines and because of those inherent
complexities deferring to local
control might be
ineffective and so when you look at the
law book that I didn't bring with me to
the
table um we have interstate compacts
with Maine and Vermont and as a quick
aside when I started at the department
of education I had a wonderful colleague
who who was guiding me those first few
months and we don't have a similar in uh
interstate compact with
Massachusetts we don't have one and it
was fascinating to me and and she said
to me jokingly she said but that's
because it takes an act of Congress and
she was right yeah it it does yeah and
we have a school district that is a
Vermont New Hampshire school and they
have struggled historically as to what
law
applies because the reality is and I'm
simplifying it so please forgive me but
the reality is the minute you go into
another state right it's just a
different
analysis and it is because of that
reason that it would be ineffective to
just say We'll defer to local control
who's local control when I worked with
the New Hampshire Vermont school and
they were struggling because they never
decided which law would be would apply
they suddenly at
odds and and their whole philosophy was
well we'll decide what law will apply
when the issue comes up and I remember
sitting in the Schoolboard meeting
going
what they just kicked the can down the
road they needed to decide which law was
going to apply and stick with it and
inevitably deferring to local control
that's going to be the problem that that
inevitably you'll run into
which law
applies and that's why in in those
situations if within the state of New
Hampshire you defer to local
control that's an effective solution and
that's for this policy body to make that
decision but anything over state lines
just gets inherently more
complicated and local control will
probably not you will probably see
immediate issues if that is how you
defer okay
yes and thank you um so I just quick did
a Google Search and the FBI does have a
cyber division which deals with these
these things because it's interstate and
not intrastate yes so thank you for
that well I didn't have the answer so
you shouldn't thank me for it but I
appreciate the no you actually put that
in my head so you know you
would but I think you're being I think
you're being a little too gracious but I
appreciate but I think your point is
well taken right it's not a it's not a
local state agency that's in charge of
that it is the FBI and it is a division
of the FBI and there's a reason for that
because you have to have that Federal
power in order to have that oversight of
the
states um so I'm thinking generally is
what we need um a few sentences is maybe
a paragraph on the topic of cyber
bullying across state lines and a
procedure that you know just looking at
things um could be
um an added subsection under um 193
F4
um and possibly also something um in F6
in terms of
reporting represent Marie thank you Mr
chair um do any of these proposed
language options regarding um either FBI
or Attorney General's office should we
get um input from those
agencies
um I don't think it would be a um
well if someone's going to contact it um
I'll do the uh local Ag and you can do
the FBI how about
that I'm just asking the question I
wanted to make sure that we're not
getting ourselves I don't think it would
be a a bad idea to um
contact UM both and uh uh indicate what
we are
considering in terms of legislation on
the subject I would agree 100% that the
Attorney General's office should be
looped into that uh language that you're
contemplating inserting in terms of the
FBI the department of safety um they
have work have contacts the FBI there
should be some contacts there they have
to clear any law that is written about
um dissemination of criminal records
with the FBI so that might be an Avenue
that that so New Hampshire Department of
Safety instead for the New Hampshire
Department of safety
okay so any further comments on Cyber
Bine across state
lines um
so uh representative Marie did you want
to contact uh
depart Department of Safety and um would
someone contact the AG's office um
representative McDonald would you do
that I can do that great and
representative muray I have a contact at
the department of safety I can send you
her information to assist you
sure representative McDonald McDonald if
you need uh assistance with the AG's
office I can yeah right I used to work
there so sometimes they still talk to me
but I appreciate it thank you of course
anything further no thank you very much
I will be in the cheap seats in the back
great if you uh if you need me thank you
so
much um you know so I I think if you
know we can accomplish something on this
topic I think that would be um a good
accomplishment uh for the committee on
on this
legislation um does anyone have any
questions representative McDonald on her
um amended language to
108 represent of hall question actually
so at the end you know it shall be
initiated by the principal or design of
the first district to learn of the
incident I'm just wondering if they
might you know they might not be sure
what's the who's the first district you
know are they going to talk to each
other and say I got it first I heard it
at 2 o' you heard it at 3 I mean is that
you envision that happening or not
really I can't imagine that happening
but I definitely understand the concern
it's not so much the first district just
that somebody is doing this which is my
goal all along um but it definitely
looks like there will be an amendment to
the amendment so I will take that under
advisement I just thought I don't know
what happened or not thank
you um uh Becky since I think school
boards association's name was mentioned
in connection with this uh Amendment
would you like toh step up to the place
good afternoon members of the committee
and chairman Celli for the record Becky
Wilson from the New Hampshire school
boards Association thank you um I do
know that Mr Christina uh and I have
worked a little bit on this after the
original hearing to try to help clear up
some of this confusion I think and to
make sure that representative McDonald's
concerns were addressed um and that you
can try to make it as clear as possible
um in these situations I think that was
the intent of offering this language so
that somebody would take the initiative
to start the investigation um if there's
other things that I can help with I'm
happy to try to address those um I think
represent um attorney Fenton probably
answered most of those questions in
terms of the legality of who can do
things across state lines I think it's
just in terms of you know the
day-to-day processing of bullying
reports and bullying inv instigations
and trying to determine when kids are
being mean to each other versus whether
or not it is a bullying situation based
on the definition that is in the law of
bullying whether or not you complete the
bullying investigation and determine it
is actually bullying I there's a lot of
pieces to this to this process um that
are very prescriptive and I think that
um just trying to make sure somebody
starts that process is the intention of
this amended language
R muray thank you I I know that we did
talk about an amendment to an amendment
um and I did I was curious to know
whether or not
um what what a general time frame for
these investigations are I know there's
conversation about granting an
additional seven school days um but I I
can imagine if these are across state
lines this may take quite some time
after the initial investigation if it
were um determined that there were other
agencies that needed to be reached I'm
just curious if anyone knows what a
general time frame for this type of
inquiry
is uh thank you for the question um
there are timelines specified in the
current bullying law in terms of how
long you have for certain parts of the
investigation and how long you have to
complete those I was just trying to pull
it up off the top of my head but
everything is I have about 800 windows
open I apologize um so there are very
formal
uh time frames for a bullying
investigation in terms of when you have
to start the bullying investigation once
you've been alerted that there is
potentially a situation that is bullying
um who has to be notified when you have
to notify them how long you have to make
a determination Etc that's all right
within the law right and part of that is
in the amendment the five days and the
seven days right right
that it is
yeah um yeah I don't know if we want to
attach any number of days to a when we
get state agencies involved um you know
yeah I would also just speak to you know
how for the administrators that are
completing the bullying investigations
or their design whoever those people are
that are doing those most often it is
the principal or an assistant principal
or something other school administrator
that is by Design to ensure that you
have a person with that um you know
level of influence at the school level
that is making those determinations and
not I think somebody had made a comment
earlier designating the PE teacher as
the bullying investigator you know there
there's some reasons why you would
typically have an administrator doing
those investigations because there are
so many time frames and legal aspects of
making sure that you're completing that
investigation with Fidelity um it's very
difficult sometimes when you get a
report of what is considered bullying
from a from a student not that it's
unfounded often times they are founded
investigations of bullying are founded
that way but I don't know if any of you
have ever worked with seventh graders
but you know you can get reports of
somebody being bullied by a seventh
grade student and by the time you get
the students together to try to
interview them and figure out what is
happening I think somebody mentioned
this earlier you find out they're just
being mean to each other it doesn't
necessarily meet the level of
qualifications of bullying but that's
why that investigation process exists to
make sure that people are going through
the process with Fidelity and ensuring
that you are making determinations about
whether or not there's actually bullying
as it's defined in the law versus
students are being mean to each other
which happens um for sure and needs to
be addressed regardless um but in a very
different way would you address a
student who has been founded as a bully
or in bullying versus a students that
are being mean to each other
resent Freeman did you thank you Mr
chairman I think I found what um what
representative Murray was looking for
under 193 F4 section I which says a
provision that the superintendent or
design May within the 48 hour period
Grant the school principal or design a
waiver from the notification requirement
if the superintendent or design deems
such waiver to be in the best interest
of the victim of perpetrator so you're
concerned with if they're working with
other agencies or other States would it
be enough time I think this provision
right there would allow that time that's
necessary to complete the investigation
to
occur and K does talk about um
requirement for the principal of design
to develop a response to remediate
The Bullying or cyber
bullying
um there there could be a line added in
a number of different locations
including the reporting in relation to
you know cyber bullying um especially
across state lines um there in in
reporting there is requirement for
bullying and cyber bullying um to be
reported um to the Department which uh
makes that available as part of a safety
report
annually um and
um we might
expand um cyber bulling on their
um just to indicate something if you
know if it's a cyber bullying within
state or um across state lines um
because you know um it'll probably will
happen and come to our attention
um while some of you are still in the
legislature yeah I would just um be ask
the committee to be mindful of the fact
that there are differences between
disciplinary consequences for bullying
versus interventions for a student who
has been founded as bullying somebody
versus the victim's interventions what
they may need if it's founded um and
certainly I think I heard something
earlier about you know feeling as though
perhaps the language didn't um you know
spell out as strongly sort of what is
the consequence for the person that has
been bullied or making sure that people
are aware that there is some sort of
disciplinary consequence but the people
that are completing these investigations
even with founded investigations of
bullying um the part of the reason
people in the district are responsible
for doing those investigations is
because they will have access to
individual student information about a
student's potential needs whether or not
they are potentially covered by special
education whether or not there are some
other you know situations or extenuating
circumstances that could be addressed in
different way other than just a
disciplinary consequence um so being
cautious about um spelling out
specifically that you want certain
consequences for certain things there's
a lot of reasons why um people may or
may not know what the consequence was
for a bully or a founded bullying
situation um there's lots of reasons
where that's probably being addressed
but perhaps not in the way people would
expect um if they're not involved sort
of in the inner workings of that
right um and just for everybody's um
timelines on this um as I mentioned 384
is an early bill I have that tentatively
scheduled for an exact session on March
3D and the other two bills
um 673 and 108 for March
10th so as we're trying to um make
contact with uh various agencies and uh
come up with some language um you know
we'll need to uh slot in some time
um you know maybe during that week of
March 5th
and everybody has all sorts of time next
week to work on these things I would
um I would just also mention quickly um
I don't know and uh attorney Fenton
could probably answer this better than I
could but what the intersection would be
for situations which would also cross
the line into a safe schools violation
um that would involve typically the
school district working alongside or at
least providing information to their
local police department um and they
would be involved and there are some
incidences bullying that I think could
on occasion rise to the level of also
falling under the safe schools violation
um so that would also involve other
agencies orus or school resource
officers Etc so right great thank you
very
much um anything else with
108 okay
um take a look at
um 673 I think was the third
bill this is repr represent of cel's
Bill
that was
um I think trying to go
down um the road of blline or cyber
buline
um uh against a quote unquote protected
class
R
Marie thank you Mr chair i h i happen to
agree that there is probably a
circumstance in which we would include
some sort of component uh potentially a
referral to the Human Rights Commission
or some sort of other circumstance with
regard to protected classes uh and and
violations targeted against them on that
nature I you know and I don't know know
if that I guess to our conversation
about combining different components of
different pieces of legislation if
that's something that we were interested
in
bringing bills together um potentially
but I do think that that is an important
part of our conversation or should
be would be human rights violations
correct I mean I I when there are acts
against a protected class is that I
guess my question is is that where that
would go to the office of Human Rights
or is that where maybe attorney Fenton
again could be helpful in that way like
I'm I'm not entirely
sure um you there's nothing in statute
now that I know of in The Bullying or
safety uh statutes in that regard um
representative McDonald uh along the
same lines thank you Mr chair I have a
question about the protected classes too
it seems to me that on line 11 and
subsequent mentions of protected class
there should be some sort of statutory
reference or maybe a list of what the
class is defined under this chapter of
law are and the reference just appears
to be absent I don't know if anyone
knows off what reference we would
include yes is that something maybe the
department knows anything about is could
they speak to
that uh I saw some hand signals from the
back so I I think that they might have
an answer in a few moments okay um smoke
signal
um yeah
you
because how how far do you go with a
bullying
case um before you go into
other
um um acts such as hate crime
legislation I don't know the answer to
that question Mr chair but I in the in
the event of a circumstance that would
warrant that I think we need to be
prepared to be able to make sure that
that is something that is enumerated
whether it is to the office of uh human
rights or or or some other entity I
don't know um but that would be dictated
by the findings I believe in the
investigation I don't know
um yeah I think with the um complaint to
the Human Rights
Commission um there uh is an issue
whether that um complaint has to come
from an initial from an
individual or um we had legislation
um in the past um and I cannot remember
the outcome I'm sure someone might
remember the outcome about uh the
ability of Department of
Education um to file a complaint with
the Human Rights Commission um because
of um situation with the um the victim
who was involved in the complaint or
multiple victims
um would each parent file a separate
complaint or would it um so there was
legislation about that I just can't
remember um what happened with it but
I'm sure someone can um and uh perhaps
that someone would be attorney
Fenton so good afternoon again just for
the record Diana Fenton with the
Department of Education um so in
reviewing and I just want to make sure I
understand and your your question
reviewing House Bill
673 relative to school bullying and
discrimination
plans I'm looking at
line 10 and 11 the targeted acts against
the protected class so your your
question in essence is is it appropriate
to report it to the Department of Ed or
the Human Rights
Commission I think it would be to the
Human Rights Commission I that makes a
logical sense on on that piece of it
yes right yes I and I guess to that end
I guess my my I am advocating for some
sort of f caveat or facet of that
language from
673 and
potentially representative
McDonald's or another like version to be
this that that portion to be enumerated
somewhere in a
new version of something we
have um do you know what happened with
uh do we now have in statute um the
ability for the Department of Education
to file a complaint with the Human
Rights
Commission so my understanding on that
law that was passed previously um the
Department of Education was not
successful in oh requesting on behalf of
an individual or School District right
requesting an investigation and to be
clear um the way the law was written and
the way it was interpreted by the
Attorney General's office and they put
out a memo on this was that the
Department of Education was not to do
the investigation of those claims of of
discrimination um those were to be
investigated by the Attorney General's
office or the Human Rights Commission
and that if there was a finding then the
department could impose discipline on in
Educator's license if that was
appropriate um but the investigation
itself was not done nor was it intended
to be done by the Department of
Education
right follow and in this circumstance
we're we're not necessarily talking
about educator licenses here we're
talking about an investigation of of
bullying incidents between pupils is
that my understanding so it's a
different set of circumstances correct I
was yes so I was answering your question
is it related to um the language in
House Bill
673 namely lines 10 and 11 and then
representative cordelli had asked a
question about the Department's ability
on a prior Bill uh So my answer was to
that but you're right this is has
nothing to do to the best of my
knowledge with educator license it's
student
buling right
so um on lines 10 and
11 if there were substantiated
incidents um the investigation conducted
locally um was found to be
um um
valid
complaint um and the victim was a member
of a protected
class um yet to be
defined um such
uh such
incident um would be reported by the um
or could be may be reported by the uh
local uh District uh to the Attorney
General's
office is yes is that
um I don't know uh uh yeah I'm not
sure would would that be a correct
summation of what I'm hearing
representative Fenton do you
think I think that's accurate based on
this committee's discussion um I know
there is
a there is a bureau or division I'm not
sure which um at the Attorney General's
office office that would handle these
types of cases and so it might be
worth a question to them to find out if
they're comfortable with the referral to
their agency or the Human Rights
Commission or or both I will defer to
them on that and also defer on the
language if it is a
shall right
um right I can definitely included that
in my questions to them
great
okay um so does
that um take care
of what we want to look at
as um
possible uh amendments to a bill or
bills
um
and um we could save
uh discussion um until we hear back from
um representative Murray and
McDonald um you know hopefully early in
March um and then um have uh some
language drafted um at some point for
Action um before
deadlines um knowing that um on March
3rd probably we will have to act on um
um so if any anyone wants
to um take anything out of 384 to
incorporate elsewhere that's that's a
possibility Also if anyone finds
anything in
384 um that we think should go
forward
sure thank you my other question is
lines 15 to 20 are we just or 15 to 19
actually are we just on is that on 673 6
on um 673 about the form which is kind
of I mean is that we need that or not
really but that's a whole new
thing
Department
to obviously go
office office here comes the attorney
yeah what of data is already there the
bill
also ask
I owe everybody a
dollar um
so the department does not receive
information about protected
classes um I will refer this committee
to the bullying report that the
department collects every year we report
out on that every November it is on our
website um and I think the
discussion was more about what is
addressed in lines 25 and 26 the
aggregate data organized by school I
think there was some discussion about
knowing more just kind of a drill down
on on what this data represents because
the department is getting it at such a
high level um and so I know that there
was some discussion about that in
November
and we can certainly go back and and
look at that discussion in more depth um
but I think a great place to start is
looking at our website and looking at
the bullying report and I can provide
that to this committee if you were
interested in that
right represent
bony yes so I have the report up and it
doesn't you know in terms of what uh
attorney Fenton said it doesn't say
protected classes but it will tell you
um incidents based on gender sexual
orientation race color or national
origin disability or physical
characteristics those are categories
already there so I think it's true what
it says is they're there but they're
there for the entire State and this is
asking for um to break it down more per
District yeah
resim thank you Mr chair and I guess my
question would be it
um when we're talking about making
informed decisions about what's
happening in our like in our districts
and spotting patterns early to be able
to respond to
incidences um would that be to drill
down to the district level uh would that
be an effective tool to be able to help
spot patterns or behaviors that are
happening towards individuals based on
race gender sexuality you name
it I'm
just I'm just concerned about privacy
issues and identification of students in
some uh districts I'm thinking of a case
that I know of uh that it might have
been easy to identify um the victims
involved with all due respect Mr Sher I
know that we already have a a a I think
it's a ruler in place around
suppressions so obviously that would
still be an effect
correct um it it could be if you put it
into the statute yeah so I guess that's
my qu sorry sorry um I share uh
representative cardelli's concerns about
privacy because if you're looking at the
numbers just Statewide in those
particular groups they're very small um
so you're looking even at if I'm looking
at sexual orientation here um there's 10
there you know so you're talking about a
lot of small numbers here and I I
honestly kind of think it's a district
or a school board you know looking at
their own individual districts rather
than having this um done St Statewide
because you're looking at so small
numbers and I do share those concerns
about student
privacy Roser
Freeman thank you Mr chairman I'm sorry
I missed that part of the conversation
because that was a point I was going to
bring up is that I was also concerned
about data being easily identified
especially in the smaller districts but
I I think also and I I I'll ask um the
attorney this um any anytime there's an
instance of a a a crime against a
protected class aren't the districts
already um uh help me with the wording I
know the word aren't they aren't they
mandated to be court reporters are they
not mandated to report those if they
suspect that it is a hate crime or a
crime against a protected class they
should be reporting that to the Attorney
General's office office of civil rights
or the Human Rights Commission yes and
and we've had instances of that
um anything further in the research
you're you've been doing attorney
Fenton no I wish I had something
brilliant to share but
um I'm just reviewing our annual
report ah
um is there anything further um it's uh
220 um we've been through the three
bills um and have some uh assignments uh
handed
out um and some time frames for moving
forward um is there anything further uh
for discussion um today on on these ban
bills great seeing none uh thank you
very much um I think it's uh been
productive and um I think we can uh get
something accomplished um this
year and um we will reconvene in um
about 10 minutes for our first hearing
of the afternoon
e
e e
which is uh
House
Bill 709 allowing parents and Guardians
to admit their children into any school
district where they pay any property or
School District
taxes
um and I do not see any
of
the
sponsors um here at the
moment
um would
um representative Freeman would you be
so kind as to introduce the bill to us
he's adding that to the notes thank
you good afternoon Mr cheer and members
of the House Education policy and
administration I'm here today to
introduce House Bill 709 which has a
fiscal note this is an act that would
allow parents or Guardians to admit
their children into any school district
where they pay any property of school
district taxes being as I am not the
prime sponsor or even a co-sponsor on
this bill I cannot speak to the merits
of the demerits of this bill but am
merely here to introduce
it thank you very much I I take it we
have no questions for representative
Freeman
um
[Music]
um yes Mr chair did we ever get an an
updated fiscal note on this not that I'm
aware of
okay that's not
uncomon uh does
anyone have any uh questions about the
bill I know
right uh
seeing none
um I I guess we'll um uh end the hearing
on this bill I'm sure we'll
yes no go ahead thank you Mr chair so
I'm just curious when you pay who pays
School District
taxes if you're not I'm just the
difference between property tax and
School District
taxes how was that differentiated I'm
just trying to think so I pay my
property tax and my school district tax
is in there isn't it or not yeah
yeah
okay right if I don't if my kids don't
wait a minute so if I don't live in the
town do I still pay school district
tax I guess that's my
question you don't live in a town you
pay your property you pay property tax
be own property but do you pay a
different School District
tag not sure but um we
uh can I see y I was just assuming that
if if someone owns like another home or
something that that's what this means so
they're paying property tax I would
imagine it also includes a school tax
it's part of the whole your bill right
that's why I wonder yeah they both
mentioned or right yes I see what you're
saying yet right I don't know if they
were trying to make a point
that pay in the school yeah so I have a
question um so sorry did I jump
you um would this also apply like say
you um own a business in another
town and you're paying property taxes on
the business but you're living in
another town um so that's my
question okay well um you we don't uh
have any answers today so
we'll
um
yes oh yes I'm sorry oh yep
so we won't close the hearing on
709 um and we welcome Barrett
Christina thank you again chairman
cordelli um I will be brief and I may
have handed in my card too early
actually um uh I don't have um specific
T we are opposed to the to House Bill
709 I have questions more than anything
else um Can the individual who pays
property or School District taxes be an
outof State resident can it be somebody
from Massachusetts who would then be
allowed to send their child to a New
Hampshire school um if they own property
in more than two locations in New
Hampshire does the child get to switch
School throughout the year for perhaps
non-academic purposes I'm going to go to
this high school because they've got a
really good hockey team but I'm going to
go to that high school because they've
got a really good basketball team um
does it apply to what I'll call
residential property only or does this
also Encompass owning commercial
commercial property in a particular town
I may have a home in conquered but my
commercial property that I own is is in
Bow is ADD enough to to allow me to
attend the school there um we have
concerns about if if residency for
School attendance purposes is broadened
to paying taxes or school taxes or
property taxes um what will else will
this open the door to will that
individual or that family be allowed to
vote at annual meeting um will they be
allowed to submit petition warrant
articles um and going back to my first
question about if it's an outof State
resident somebody who lives in
Massachusetts but also owns a a home
here um does that person qualify for
instate tuition to the university system
the UNA your P the state or or Keen or
or whatnot um and also I think there's
an in an unforeseen
um uh uh an unforeseen aspect of this
bill um we know currently that it says
the child attends the school where one
of the parents
resides this removes The Residency
aspect I guess it doesn't it says or
where's the person so never mind on that
aspect so those are the questions nsba
nhba has um one aspect I did a quick
Word Search the word residency appears
in New Hampshire statutes I believe 63
times um some of them are about you know
additional Grant programs you have to be
a resident of the state it doesn't talk
about anything about paying taxes or
anything like that so um you know
there's some there's
some aspects in in current law that
speak about being a a resident of the
state or a resident of a town and with
that I'll I I'll close my comments and
happy to answer any questions any
questions see none thank you very much
thank you
and now I can close the
hearing on uh House Bill 79 and we have
a little bit of time until um our last
bill of the
day
e
e e
all right we're going to open the
hearing on House Bill 741 FN allowing
parents to send their children to any
school district they choose and I
welcome the prime sponsor representative
cordelli uh thank you chairman
Noble uh thank you fellow committee
members uh for the record Glen cordelli
representing tufton bro wolf bro and OA
in the beautiful Lakes
Region and it's uh my pleasure to
present uh House Bill
7401 excuse
me I believe in education freedom and
that includes Public
Schools this bill expands our current
open enrollment statutes to say that all
schools are open enrollment schools that
a public school student can attend the
public school of their choice whether is
in the same district or
not let's um walk walk you through the
bill if I
might um on page one it starts with the
uh compulsory attendance statutes and it
eliminates on line four the uh
requirement that the child is assigned
to their resident School District
in uh
on further down on that first page um it
eliminates uh much of the language about
School attendance and um uh residency
and residency
disputes um which is not uh necessary um
in this uh
legislation on page two there are
several definitions
changes um and this is all in the open
enrollment statutes um that are on the
books
now
um so there is um a definition change to
open enrollment public
school um online's uh 1617 this just an
update uh of the uh uh Federal
legislation to every every student
succeeds
act um then in section six starting on
line
21 uh the bill states that each district
shall be an open enrollment uh school
and that there is to be a policy to
allow students to transfer within
district from one District to another in
the state or or in any state where that
we have an interstate compact that does
not require uh non-resident pupils to
pay application uh fees uh that's in
lines 22 to
um down further on lines 30 to
36 it requires each district to post
capacity information
uh capacity information for each School
in the district each grade level and
vacancies in each individual
school on the first of the month each
month so that we have so parents looking
to possibly transfer to another school
has information about that
school uh each each school district will
also report that uh annually to the uh
Commissioner of education and the
commissioner shall publish that
information on the State
website on page
three Midway down on starting on line 17
Romans
7 um very important um it lists the four
reasons that a district may deny a
transfer
application only these four reasons um
pretty much Behavior
related following that en Roman
8 it specifies no receiving school or
District shall accept or reject an
application based upon grade age levels
pupil needs academic
aptitude or athletic
achievement we don't want uh schools um
public schools out recruiting um
basketball players or hockey
players um at then at the bottom of the
page IT addresses Transportation since
that um I knew would be a question and
and um
the uh neither the sending or receiving
District shall be obligated to provide
transportation
services uh for a student uh outside the
resident
District uh but the parent can work to
provide transportation to a bus stop on
an existing bus route of the receiving
school on page four
um there is a section um Roman uh 11 um
particularly um that is crossed out and
is the subject of an
amendment um which I'll go over in a
second it's Amendment
0336 uh further down on lines uh 20 on
uh talks about a funding
and this is basically the same funding
that is in law
now in that uh the resident District
shall provide not less than 80% of the
district's average cost per puple to the
receiving
District um that's current law for open
enrollment and I'll mention that um
Senator Waters over in the Senate has
Senate Bill 99
which provides open enrollment to go to
CTE
centers so you can go to the CTE Center
of your choice and the same funding
mechanism would apply for a full-time
student going to that c CTE Center 80%
of the funds would follow the student so
um so we're Senator Waters and I are
coming at from it from two different
angles I'm covering
um Regular public schools and he's
covering uh CTE centers which I think is
important
um and on page six I'll just mention oh
excuse me page
five um at the bottom I repeal two
sections of current
statute um D3 and D4 D3 is
relates to adoption of uh enrollment
open enrollment status by a district
that's part of the current legislation
but is not needed since all schools will
be open enrollment
schools and um
D4 uh is related to uh uh limits on um
pupil
selection
um so that is a summary of the bill um I
wanted to mention the uh the amendment
that is I hope before each one of you
which is
0336 H and the top part Romans 7 is
really um the key here and that
addresses uh children of
military uh
personnel and they shall be given
admission preference over a non-resident
pupil um and that replaces the current
military section and um I think you'll
be hearing more testimony about this U
from another uh
presenter but that's the amendment and
that encompasses the
bill um I also provided you with a
letter from uh the uh Superintendent at
uh Prospect mountains School uh Mr
broadrick and this talks about um the
situation that his school is currently
in they are an enroll open enrollment
school and they are having some
difficulties with districts who are
trying to send or districts whose
students are coming to his district um
as open enrollment students but what I
wanted to draw your attention to in
particular in this letter is the the uh
final couple of lines in the last
paragraph and they
state public school programs public
school choice programs like open
enrollment answer one of the critici
criticisms I often hear of voucher and
other choice programs that such programs
take public money out of public
education but open enrollment keeps
public dollars in public
schools public school choice merely
introduces an element of competition
that encourages our public schools to
meet more family
needs and that's from the superintendent
at Prospect
Mountain um
residency um there are
companies one that I found in particular
verify residence.com um you can hire
them to go out and check on people
residents to see if they're actually in
the Resident School District that
they're supposed to be going
to um we have had cases around the
country where parents have been
jailed for using a relative's address to
go to a different public
school um in
2011 uh Kelly Williams bowler spent nine
days in jail after being convicted
convicted of a felony for enrolling her
teenage daughters into school using her
father's
address she was then pardoned by the
then governor of the
state
in
um in
a Academy mom said she would never
forget the night when she and her four
kids were leaving home to go out for
dinner and two men who had been hired by
the school district approached her to
verify their residency in the
neighborhood personally
um some of you might know that um just
under two years ago my grandson was born
missing one quarter of his
heart he spent the first seven months of
his life um in uh Pediatric Intensive
Care the hospital told my daughter you
have to be within a half an hour of the
hospital at all times she lived an hour
away what was she going to do she's a
special ed teacher and she one of her
pupils parents owned or excuse me leased
a condo 15 minutes from the
hospital it was vacant and she let them
use that that for seven or eight months
free of
charge that condo that she
leased wasn't used because they just
leased it to use that address to send
one of their children to that local
school
district um I could tell you other
personal stories also
um but that I think um happens to
regularly um around the
country um and at least 26 states have
legislation that
criminalizes using the wrong uh address
for School
attendance and let me just mention a few
polls on this
topic um October
2023 from a group called yes every kid
and you
government showed that 84% of school
parents supported K12 open
enrollment in July
2024 Ed Choice polling shows that 73% of
school parents supported open
enrollment 69% of Republicans 81% of
Democrats and
71% of Independence
I think that public
schools should be open to all students
like public parks like public
libraries competition as the
superintendent in Prospect Mountain
pointed out will work to benefit all
public schools and all
students and provide for greater
achievement and success for those
students I believe that open enrollment
and public school choice is one answer
to the problems that we see with
academics in the State uh satisfaction
of students student behavioral issues
and many other things um if students can
attend the school that meets their needs
and in which they're happy I think the
entire system and the state will be
better off thank you thank you
representative cordelli any
questions representative Hall you madam
chair um I have a question about the the
parents that were punished for lying
about where they lived and whatnot I
mean were they punished because they
broke the law yes okay thank
you any other questions I I I will
mention um one's story about them I read
was that um she and her child or
children split time between her house
and her father's house and it was was
her father's house that used uh that she
used their address um for a school
enrollment in a school near his
house any other questions oh represent
of
H thank you again for taking my question
can you like just just take a school
district and and like picture what this
all looks like I I'm I'm you know they
got a few spaces available or you just
you know process many many if not most
schools um public schools in the state
are facing declining
enrollment and have capacity and I
believe there are schools that are
looking to to outside their
boundaries um to to uh attract students
um and this provides them the legal
mechanism to do so um I liveed in
Tuftonboro and our kids um used to go to
Molten Boro uh for
school um they now go to wolfboro but
there are certainly some areas of tuen
Boro that are closer to Molten
Boro um once you get Beyond um element
El School uh closer to Molten Boro than
they are to uh to
wolfboro um if um this law uh were if
this bill were to become law would some
of those children choose to go to Molten
Boro
again
possibly I'm not sure I don't
know thank you taking my question um so
financially
the the local school where the where the
seats are if those are filled by
somebody else it's not going to be any
cost to that
town yeah I know you mentioned the 80%
but I mean is this like 80% from the
resident um School District would follow
the child to the receiving school
district and the 20% would stay with the
um sending
District okay thank you
representative muray thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um with regard to page three of
the underlying bill um lines 27 through
37 um we're talking about Transportation
here it is there any
um mileage limit like distance between
um in
which you know could could potentially
somebody in Coos County enroll their
based on this bill uh enroll their
student in a another District
uh on the southern part of the state I
mean I guess my question is um it I know
that there is a conversation about
additional costs but to what end are we
talking about distance traveled and how
long a student is potentially
on a bus a vehicle neither sending nor
the receiving School District shall be
obligated to provide transportation
services um it so uh I certainly can see
um a a parent um let's say in Caroll
County where I am um working in bellnap
or Grafton County and um uh taking their
child um to a school over closer to
where they work and driving them to
school
we we actually had
legislation um uh last
term um it was ultimately defeated uh
but would have allowed um uh someone
working at a school outside of their
resident District to um enroll their
child in that school where they
worked followup Madam chair uh so my I I
guess and then my other question is
should a a a student or a pupil receive
uh specialized services that require
Transportation um um what special ed
services um would be um the requirement
of the resident District um just like
with
um uh charter schools and that's on uh
Roman 2 um which I neglected to point
out on um page
four okay uh yes
follow one final followup if I may Madam
chair yes okay thank you is there a
world in which a student with special
needs could be on a a bus or a
transportation for for an hour two hours
like I mean depending I I uh I would not
foresee
that of B Bon thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question on page
two lines
uh uh 29 through 35 um it's talking
about each School District shall
determine for each School in the
district the capacity of each School in
each grade level and it says the school
districts will post the total capacity
who who DET who has the responsibility
of determining that capacity because
capacity can change depending upon the
individual needs of a classroom um so
how if
you just from my Schoolboard experience
and you're looking at different
classroom compositions you might need a
smaller capacity in that class I mean
capacity could refer to how many kids
you can put in the room um right so yes
um well that's why
um it would be posted each month um but
also talks about each um each grade
level so is it your thought that the
school will determine how many yes so
it's completely up to the school to
decide yes is it U it would be similar
to um the way it's done um we had a bill
about um unused space um and Charter
Schools um and again that would the
unused space would is determined by the
school followup please follow um so then
the other aspect of that it says that um
you're by the first of the month so if I
read this correctly you're you people
would be able to transfer into uh
established classrooms throughout the
school year depending upon the capacity
correct representative Murray thank you
madam chair what happens if a student uh
uh you know transfers in to a district
and they don't happen to be at the same
place in their learning Academic Year as
their previous School uh is there some
onus on the district then to provide
services to either catch that student up
or if they're completely at a different
place as determined by each district
because the districts and the school
boards um approve their curriculums for
the year and they they look different
across districts how do you ensure that
you don't have a student every month
walking into a different academic
setting where they may be way ahead or
way behind I I think it would be um the
same as if a student moved into a new
school district and enrolled in that new
school district during the school year
um they would evaluate um where they
were and accommodate that student um I
don't see it um any different for an
open enrollment student than someone
moving into the
district Madam chair but uh you did say
that the census numbers could change
potentially monthly correct so if a
student enrolled one month at school a
is there a possibility that they could
in two months three months time enroll
elsewhere um I I would think that um if
they enrolled um uh if for instance um
child from uh Tuftonboro enrolled uh in
the Middle School in um molten Boro um
and after a couple of months found
um that um it was not the right fit for
them um or um there were some uh other
problems there at the school um then um
they would be free to transfer back to
uh uh tuffen Boro and go to the wolfboro
Regional
School representative
Freeman thank you madam chair I actually
have two questions if you'll indulge me
thank you representative cordelli for
taking my question so from what I've
gathered from the the the Crux of this
bill this doesn't take away any local
control of the districts is that correct
I don't believe so thank you and my
second question is and to address some
of the the concerns about people coming
and going and coming and going right now
in um in the larger cities in New
Hampshire Manchester and nationa don't
they deal with very
transient um
populations um that is my understanding
that they do um from talking to people
from uh from
Manchester thank
you representative Hall you madam chair
thank you for taking my question how
does the school district decide who they
take let's say 10 special needs students
want to come to Bo because they've heard
the program is good and maybe there are
there I mean and they only have room for
two how is that decided upon um uh first
they would take the the first two
applying the first come first serve no
matter who the kids are oh sorry
followup sure okay so it's a first come
first serve when the seats open they get
it right and cut and the followup to
that
um how does this affect SAU budgets
School District budgets I mean can they
budget for all these people coming
in uh they don't even know what they're
going to cost right right oh they have
uh children moving in during the school
year um
uh I I don't you know I'm not
envisioning um you know busloads of
students um moving from um you know tuen
Boro to Molten Boro um
uh
um I I don't have statistics with me on
um states that have open enrollment
about how how many students are involved
um but I know that um from what I read
um in in
Wisconsin um where they have uh a open
enrollment
um I think it was 31% of the students
were in um rural
areas thank you any other
questions representative B Bon thank you
madam chair um thank you for taking my
question uh would it be possible for you
to uh share with us your research um and
the states that have these policies in
place so that uh we would have some type
of comparison yes M sure thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much Mary wilky
good afternoon um thank you for taking
my testimony I'm Mary Wilkey I live in
conquer I'm a retired public school
teacher and I oppose this bill um two
main reasons the first is uh at a time
when we have such big gaps between um
rich and poor in our culture our society
um I feel that open these open
enrollment bills this one and some of
the other ones that have been uh
proposed tend to favor The Haves and
disadvantage the Have Nots um people I I
heard um Senator Lang um introduced a
similar bill in the Senate and said that
these bills are prioritizing what's best
for each individual student and I feel
like that's the sentiment behind many of
bills like this as well as some other
privatization kinds of bills um but I
don't think they really do I think
they're Pro this bill prioritizes
students who qualify for transfers so
students who don't have discipline
issues who haven't been absent a lot who
um haven't ever been expelled um
students whose parents can provide the
transportation to another District which
tend to be parents who have more means
um and then there's the other group who
we should also prioritize and we aren't
talking about them we're talking about
giving a certain group of people a
privilege but ignoring the rest
and um so if we have uh for instance two
students in a district and uh one
transfers to a new District because she
wants to take French and her District
provides no foreign language because
they don't they're a property poor town
and um her best friend wants to take
French too but her parents can't afford
to get her to provide transportation or
they don't have the time to provide
transportation to the other District or
she maybe her parents have uh substance
abuse issues that's caused her to be
absent a lot so she doesn't get that
opportunity what are we doing to
prioritize her I feel like we have to
prioritize every single child in New
Hampshire schools and the only reason we
can prioritize both of those children
and make sure they both get foreign
language which is a it's not something
like you know having um major theater in
their school some huge theatrical uh
opportunity it's it's a basic that we
all expect in our high schools if we the
only way we can prioritize that for both
of them is to make sure that the
original School District can offer
foreign language and the way we can do
that is to make sure that every district
has the amount of funding they need to
provide the basics that are in our Core
Curriculum in our adequacy uh laws um
and then the um and and because also as
students who have the means and who fit
the qualifications leave their District
the students who left behind are the
ones whose parents don't have the means
to help them do it or who have
disciplinary issues whatever the issues
are they are they tend to be more than
average in terms of the expense of
educating them and yet more resources
are leaving and so they're going to be
left with fewer resources than they had
when students started leaving their
district and the second issue is and I'm
I I wonder if when I read on page four
line 23 saying how much how the money
goes between the two districts I read it
differently than you intended
representative cordelli I thought it it
says the pupils resident District shall
pay to the receiving District the am an
amount equal to not less than 80% of
that District's average cost I thought
it meant the receiving districts I think
it would be good to clarify if you I
think you what you said was you meant it
to be the sending District um but
assuming that it's the sending District
um for instance um
Portsmith Elementary's cost per pupil as
of 2024 was $26,000 about newcastle's
right next door was 35,000 I mean I'm
sorry
44,000 if Portsmith sends
80% to Newcastle because per student who
leaves Portsmith to go to Newcastle
Elementary um then Portsmouth is giving
Newcastle $
21,000 a year for those students while
Newcastle taxpayers
are paying 44,000 per year minus
whatever is coming from the federal
government um and the state government
um so and I know this is the
same uh formula that's already in the
law but the law right now is voluntary
and this makes it involuntary as I
understand it I don't think Newcastle
can say we don't want to participate
because this is going to suddenly really
change our budget in a way we don't want
so um and and just one last thing is uh
did I lose it whoops I think I left it
behind um oh it was never mind I had one
more point but somebody else raised it
so those were my main issues about this
Bill thank you thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you Melissa wette
good
afternoon honorable members of the
committee the Department of Defense is
grateful for the opportunity to provide
comment on the policies reflected in
House Bill 741 as it relates to flexible
enrollment options for military families
with schoolage children my name is
Melissa wette and I'm the New England
region liaison at theed United States
Department of Defense State liaison
Office operating under the direction of
the under secretary of defense for
personnel and Readiness we represent the
department and establish relationships
with state and local leaders on issues
currently impacting our service members
and their families approximately
185,000 US military children move
between schools annually military
families are at a disadvantage when it
comes to enrollment options available to
their children due to the timing of
military directed moves military
families move frequently and change
school systems upwards of 10 times prior
to graduation in addition to planned
permanent change of station moves
military families often experience
additional subsequent relocations from
temporary to permanent housing due to
limited availability of military or
community housing at the time of their
arrival allowing military families to
enroll their children in the school
district they know they'll permanently
reside in will help to facilitate their
uninterrupted educational progress and
smooth integration into their new
communities and relieve undue stress
during their transition between military
duty assignments with approximately 1300
active duty service members and 800
active duty children attending school in
New Hampshire this committee has an
opportunity to have a highly impactful
and positive effect on the educational
experiences of military connected
children the Department of Defense is
hopeful to discuss options to protect
the enrollment options for these
families as such we have offered an
amend m to the current bill which will
not change the general policy but
clarify that military connected students
would have preference over non-resident
pupils should their parents be on active
duty orders and clarifying that military
connected students be exempt from school
capacity limits basically speaking the
amendment uh the amended language would
not uh or would retain current law so
incurrent law military connected
children have uh these available options
but it was stricken uh with house house
bill 741 so the amend amended language
that we have provided uh to uh the chair
would put uh those families back into uh
the bill so in closing we are grateful
for the tremendous efforts New Hampshire
has historically made to support our
military families and service members we
appreciate the opportunity to support
the policies reflected in the bill and
thank chairman cordelli for his
willingness to review our proposed
amendment thank you for taking the time
to consider and deliberate on this issue
and at this time I stand ready to answer
any questions you may have thank you
anybody have any questions
representative Bon thank you madam chair
and thank you for typing my question um
forgive me if I'm not as uh um
knowledgeable about what currently is
provided for uh children of military
families um you're talking about
military families moving amongst
different locations Statewide so across
the country from one duty station to
another so those PCS moves the military
family may move from San Diego
California to uh the Portsmouth Naval
Shipyard so they may move to uh a res uh
residents in the state of New Hampshire
followup so my question is I I'm not
understanding how this would change
anything because if you had a military
family and they came and they say they
came and they went to Portsmouth and
that's where they're they're residing um
and then they
to San are you're talking about children
that are left behind with family members
being able to say because if if the
family's moving to San Diego and then
they move back why wouldn't they already
be so under under current New Hampshire
law military families have preference if
their if their parents are are active
duty service members so that that
service member is on orders uh that
pupil has the ability to enroll in the
school district of their choice no
matter their residents because they may
have moved from temporary to permanent
housing so that family can register uh
and enroll their child in the school
district that they know they're going to
reside in this bill struck the military
uh connected children out of uh this the
statute um so we're trying to get it we
are respectively asking the committee to
include the military family uh so that
those children have access to open
enrollment policies and retain those
open enrollment options which are
currently in New Hampshire
statute uh so just to be perfectly clear
what you're saying is the original Bill
took away that ability Andre you're just
advocating for it to remain the same
correct okay thank
you representative Freeman thank you
madam chairman thank you for coming in
front of us and um I I I don't know if
you were aware of the amendment that
representative cordelli had put in which
actually added the language right back
into this bill yep we worked with the
chairman on that thank you thank you any
other
questions representative Hall chair and
thank you for taking my question I'm
just curious on let's say when you said
that they are exempt even if the school
has reached capacity limits what happens
I mean are there fire codes that say
that a school district can only have so
many students I maybe not I'm just
curious I'm unaware of those specifics
but um broadly speaking the the roughly
17 states that have enacted some sort of
open enrollment for military to children
have had that capacity uh limit revised
so that those particular families um Can
enroll their child due to those military
service
orders thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Barett Christina
thank you madam Vice chair good
afternoon members of the committee bar
Rino New Hampshire school boards
Association excuse me we are opposed to
House Bill 741 I will follow up with
written comments um as this is a similar
Bill to Senate Bill 101 which was heard
in Senate education a few weeks ago and
I wrote written comments to that
committee as well too so I can basically
copy and paste I think I've got about
five or six points that I want to
identify um first create and I'll try
not to read exactly from from my notes
here um creating an open enrollment
system a Statewide open enrollment
system would interfere with dozens if
not scores of existing tuition
agreements that exist across the state
that have been duly bargained negotiated
and agreed to by Untold number of local
school districts and school boards um
more importantly many of these tuition
agreements have um um a a requirement
that the sending School District send a
certain number or a certain percentage
of students to the receiving School
District so the receiving School
District can properly budget and they
know how many kids they're going to be
getting in any given year um the so the
bill was silent on what we would do with
those existing tuition contracts whether
or not they expire whether or not the
state law would supersede them but it
would create Havoc for the dozens if not
scores of school districts that are
already parties to um to to tuition
contracts and tuition agreements
Statewide
um page two lines 28 through 32 talks
about um uh each month uh principal or
or somebody's going to have to identify
what the capacity of each school and
each grade level is um and the capacity
of each grade level the number of
vacancies in each individual school um
and HSB finds it paradoxical that many
bills across both Chambers um of the New
Hampshire General Court last session and
this session complained about school
districts having too many administrators
um I can count to dozens of bills over
the last number of years that just put
what I'll call busy work under the hands
of school administrators rather than
focusing on curriculum instruction or
assessment and hsba would rather those
administrators had time to focus on
reading scores and writing scores and
math scores and not filling out reports
um or filling out data to send to the
Department of Education that has nothing
to do with curriculum instruction or
assess ment third uh page two line 30
speaks to districts having to post the
quote total capacity close quote of each
individual School NHS nsba asks the
total capacity of what is it student
enrollment is it empty seats is it a
school district's fiscal capacity we're
coming up on annual meetings we know
different districts have different
fiscal capacities Staffing capacity
Transportation capacity the bill is not
clear and do not accurately reflect the
numerous capacities in quotation marks
that school districts have to
encounter um fourth related to a school
district's fiscal capacities um the bill
House Bill 741 does not adequately
consider School District budgeting as I
talked about with the with the the
tuition contracts a school district or a
school board has to know roughly how
many kids they're going to have in any
given year so they can budget
accordingly um my exam if this Builder
were go through a school district would
potentially have to potentially would
potentially have to budget at 100% of
the various capacities I mentioned
preceding a school district with a
student enrollment of 500 students but
with a quote unquote capacity of 700
students would have to budget for those
700 students um this would not be
fiscally prudent and would play tax
would play Havoc with local tax rates if
we had kids coming and going um at will
if you will without a clear concept or
clear notion of how many kids are going
to be in a school district in any given
in any given year
um uh also related to I'll just call it
the enrollment capacity or the capacity
per classroom um what happens if
nonresident students fill that capacity
and then resident students move into
that school district um are they given
First Choice does the school district
going to have to hire another teacher um
is they're going to have to build
another Wing more par professionals it
sort of gets to the total scope of this
relative to how districts are going to
budget in any given school year and what
we mean by quote unquote capacity um but
the C bill is silent on on on these
particular matters um last somebody had
mentioned a great number of transient
students in in some of our communities
um you know students who through
unfortunate circumstances are required
to move to a dist District multiple
district from District to District
multiple times a year how this is that
our true reflection of the student
enrollment capacity that is that is that
is listed throughout the bill um you
know further we'd also posit that having
a significant number of transient
students is not a true reflection of the
district's sort of quote unquote
capacity um last I'll leave you with um
there's another bill relative to is
House Bill 771 representative Pell's
bill was heard in um the Ed funding
committee a week or so ago um maybe
maybe two weeks ago at at this point
also tweaking RSA
194d um I should let you know that uh
representative chairman cordelli
mentioned the prospect Mountain School
District and he received an email or a
letter from the superintendent of that
school district um there is ongoing
litigation between Prospect mountain and
another school district relative to the
interpretation of the current open and R
Roman bill um uh the current open and
Roman statute if you will um to my
knowledge that's still pending before
the New Hampshire Supreme Court um so
there just there's issues over who has
the obligation to pay without prior
notice to a school district what happens
if a parent unilaterally changes places
CH changes placements relative to
special education Transportation so on
and so forth so um it's a complicated
matter um I raised some issues and some
some concerns NH hsba has with the bill
if you'd like I can follow up with
written testimony um but that will
conclude my testimony I'm happy to
answer any questions that the committee
may have
thank you representative McDonald thank
you chairwoman Noble and thank you again
for your testimony does your
organization have any connections to
other states that have done this and
have been able to do it successfully
thank you for the question
representative um that was mentioned in
Senate Ed as well too that a number of
states have these open enrollment um
Provisions um I know one number was
floated and Senate I don't know what it
is I do have connections where I can do
some research and find that out quickly
I can get that how accurate how in
totality um nhba does not have a lot of
capacity with only four staff members so
I can certainly try and do some research
I know I'm sure representative Cordell I
know he's very thorough in his research
as well too I can see what I can find
out and pass belong to the committee
though thank you thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair uh thank you for taking my
question I have two if I may Madam chair
sure okay thank you um first question is
with regard to the hiring process do you
have any concerns that that process
could become hurried or rushed in the
event that school census numbers would
change or fluctuate on a month-to-month
basis thank thank for the question
representative I hadn't contemplated or
considered that and I forget if if the
bill just does the bill have a deadline
as to when you have
to quote unquote transfer or is it at
any time I mean if it's at any time you
know it it it it it would it would
potentially be problematic or CA a
district with Staffing with a local
issue I mean you know we have a shortage
of not a shortage of certified teachers
per se but you know once you get into
May June July and August it's hard to
find teachers especially with specific
you know um expertise if you will Math
teachers science teachers are hard to
come by um the other aspect too is
depending on the needs of that
individual child I don't know any school
district in New Hampshire that is at
quote unquote full capacity with the
number of par professionals that they
need um so you know a kid moves in
changes School let's say over Christmas
break and they they show up on January
2nd but that kid's IEP says they need a
one-on-one or or or supportive help in a
school in in their in their classroom
that could be a significant
Challenge and second question thank you
madam chair is with regard to something
that I had just been thinking as we were
talking here could this bill
unintentionally impact uh matters of
like children child and family law like
custody agreements like who has
jurisdiction to enroll their child in a
in an in a place yeah thank you for the
question uh representative I have
limited knowledge of sort of what I'll
just call the divorce proceedings and
the parenting plans there is a provision
currently in the um in the in the
current residency statute RSA 193 CO2
that does say that um that the if a
parents are divorced and liveing in
different towns that the parents can
choose what school the child will attend
um and I mean I think I don't know I'm
this is anecdotally um you know I don't
never practice divorce law I think that
um I think that the parenting plans will
generally say that you know Mom has a
you know the child will live with Mom
and attend the the school where mom
lives or the child will child will live
with Mom and attend where mom lives or
the child will live with Dad and attend
school where the dad lives however I
know the parties are at least free to
determine themselves where the child's
going to attend but you know if that
that's I think that's more of a divorce
law issue than it is necessarily an open
enrollment or a school law issue yeah I
don't want to say anything that that
would be
inaccurate y any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you David Trumble
thank you madam chairwoman my name is
David and committee members hello uh my
name is David Trumble I'm from the town
of where uh I have concerns about this
bill and there's I guess three of them
the first is I think that it would
exacerbate the inequities in New
Hampshire's system as has been mentioned
open enrollment as a concept is based on
the idea of choice that every child
should have a choice but that's only
going to be fair if every child has the
opportunity to get adequate education in
their home school the first necessary
step in order to have a fair open
enrollment program would be that every
homeschool provides every child with an
adequate education one of the states
that does open enrollment is Michigan
and according to the latest statistics
from the US Census they provide as a
state 55% of the funds for their schools
New Hampshire by that same data is
27.9% so they're providing twice as much
as we do so in Michigan every single
school is reasonably well funded so you
don't have the issue of Haves and Have
Not so you wouldn't have people wanting
to flee a school because it's so
massively underfunded but that would
certainly happen in New
Hampshire um if you look at New
Hampshire the unique feature that makes
up our school system is the heavier
Reliance on the property taxes it's the
heaviest in any state in America we are
the lowest spending state of all 50
states we give 27% of the funds to the
schools from the state we're at the
bottom we are the last state that's
ready for an open enrollment policy even
if you think it's a good idea step one
would be to fund the public schools
adequately first once that happens then
you could say okay maybe open enrollment
would work but as long as you have gross
in equities it won't work just look at
some schools in the state can only spend
$14,000 a pupil the average is 21,000
some spend 30 or 40,000 why is that
because their local property tax base
isn't high enough what's the result of
that educationally look at the
proficiency scores at the doe Newport
less than 10% of the kids are at
category three or four out of 1 2 three
and four of proficiency Charlestown 10%
Claremont 18% where 22% Statewide
average is just a little short of 40%
Bedford 69
Hopkinton 61% conquered 54% sunap I
don't have it but I know it's quite High
the point being that children who live
in Newport could easily say CIP is next
door I want to go there because they
have a tax base that can support a good
school this would be exacerbating the
diff differences the lowincome family in
Newport who can't transport their child
all the way over to stie but can easily
take their child to a bus in Newport
report they're not going to be eligible
to participate in this children who have
discipline problems are not going to be
eligible to participate in this we know
the studies show that children with
disabilities are expelled have have
discipline issues at schools I should
say at a much higher rate two three four
or five times higher than children
without disabilities children of color
for for the same behaviors EG uh using
their cell phone in class are
disciplined at a much higher rate five
to 10 times more than white children so
what's going to happen is you're going
to have some children who cannot
participate in this program because the
reasons why you can deny somebody is
they they have discipline problems
people who can't access it because of of
Transportation you're going to and and
then 80% of the money for the children
who do leave those whose parents can
afford to go over to the town that
spends a lot of money on their schools
80% of the money goes with them so now
Newport has even less money to educate
the children who are left behind if the
state of New Hampshire did its job and
funded every every school adequately
then you could see a case for open
enrollment but you wouldn't see as many
people wanting to flee that Newport
school as you would right now until you
adequately do job one it's premature for
this one my second concern is that this
tramples all over local control a
question was asked would it reduce local
control and the answer was no it it
dramatically reduces local control right
now you have a voluntary open enrollment
system in New Hampshire that's the
perfect solution in a state that doesn't
have state funding for the schools
voluntary if a town wants to open its
doors to more students they can do that
in the present system this bill reduces
and takes away local control and forces
that on everybody also has been
mentioned the issue of budgeting every
school district goes through their their
budgets and their pages and Pages how
would you budget for this you have to
budget by year but every month you have
to send in capacity differences there's
no way that you could properly budget
for either the school board is going to
over budget and think oh what if we get
a whole bunch of new people who come in
students and they don't come in but
you're still taxing at that rate your
taxpayers are going to be IR rate that's
not fair to them to have to be taxed at
that rate or they're going to under
budget the problem with that is that
most schools small schools will leave a
couple of slots open because they know
some people are going to move in during
the year but now if they under budget
they won't have the money for those
right now they have a system they can
budget for what they can budget for they
know they live a couple spots open this
this bill would trample all over the for
the local people the local school
budgets trying to manage what they're
doing the other question that comes up
is what about a fifth grader who
transfers in to another school and then
says I like it over there in that middle
school but the next year that district
has people who move into the town and
fill up all their slots so now that is
does that student have a right to go
there for sixth seventh and eighth grade
or is it an annual thing if you're not
the resident of the school so it this
isn't really contemplated in any of the
things just lastly to finish up there
was a question about people who get
arrested for using the wrong address I
mean the reason why somebody would do
that in New Hampshire is because they
know that that address has a really
strong school system but if you're not
living there you're not paying your your
family nuclear unit is not living there
you're not paying the property taxes to
support that really good school system
that's the reason why if we it's because
we don't adequately fund our schools
then the other question was about
declining enrollments there's some
schools that want more students those
schools can do that right now under
current law because you have voluntary
open enrollment if a school wants to do
it they can do it now this bill forces
every school to do it and it's going to
create chaos in our school system and
most importantly it will just exacerbate
the inequalities that's the greatest
problem in New Hampshire's education is
the inequalities between the Haves and
the Have Not school systems until you
solve that this is It's that's the first
step then you can consider open
enrollment at least that's would be my
opinion thank you thank you any
questions representative Murray thank
you madam chair um and thank you for
taking my question so my question to you
would be I I think based on what you
were saying would it be accurate to say
that you're there's a concern regarding
further segregating either through
socioeconomic status or are historically
marginalized communities that that would
increase based If This Were to move
forward in that way absolutely because
in a town every town has different
socioeconomic statuses and students who
have disabilities and those who don't
but people would be those who have more
money would be able to access the
driving and the transportation and those
whose children have not been uh
disciplined would be able to access so
the people who would get left behind uh
would be low-income families and
students who have discipline issues so
you're going to even exacerbate even
more the halves and the have
knots any other questions
representative McDonald thank you madam
chair and welcome back to education Mr
tble nice to see you uh the sponsor
mentioned that there we have no reason
to expect a bus load of students or at
least he doesn't expect that and if
that's the case we're talking a
relatively small number of
students and you use the word exasperate
so how would a small number of students
taking advantage of this cause chaos and
exasperate the system if it's just a
small number and the other school was
willing to take a few they could do that
right now so if the town that has a
great well-funded school system says oh
we could handle five more and they were
willing to do that they could do that
right now but by mandating it you you
force every school every month to come
up with a number of slots that they're
going to have in in every uh every every
classroom so there's no guarantee that
it wouldn't be a significant number um
you you could easily see parents in a
town that has a struggling functioning
school system say this is my ticket out
and so they could they could very easily
try and access this system and I'm not
saying those kids don't deserve a great
education my point is that every child
deserves a great education and if we
only funded them in the first place
where they were they wouldn't say I want
to get out of my school system okay
thanks Mr triple yeah any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Deborah house
okay good afternoon chairman Noble and
members of the House Education policy
committee uh good to be with you this
afternoon uh my name is Deborah H I am
president of the American Federation of
teachers New Hampshire I'm here to speak
against uh House Bill 741 we have oppose
this bill because it is a mandate um we
would like to be able to support this
bill but as a previous speaker said we
cannot support this bill until all of
our students in the grand state have the
opportunity of a great robust public
education in every single um local
neighborhood Public School in every
school district since the state is not
meeting its constitutional obligation to
fund that and that opportunity varies
widely from one District to another
because they are currently funded 70%
with local property tax um money we
cannot support open enrollment um if we
can fix that first problem we can have
this conversation maybe in a few years
okay um but this is a mandate it does
require local districts to adopt an open
enrollment policy and to allow for
transfers between districts unless there
is not capacity or the student has a
discipline issue or an absentee issue um
that means that the sending district has
to agree to send and the receiving
district has to agree to receive um
previous you know currently that is
something that they can work out
considering the best interest of that
particular student but also the
um needs of the receiving school when
they look at the other students in the
classroom that receive that student the
staff level they have whether they they
can meet the academic and um you know
social behavioral needs of the student
coming in as well as all the other
students in the classroom so they can
balance all of those things out and if
it works out they usually will agree but
they don't have to this law if it pass
this bill if it passes would make it a
have to so yes it is uh stepping on
local control
um let's
see so when I look at this I think about
how it would play out in my school
district I live in
Hudson and we are one of the lower
funded school districts in the area we
are a town that uh struggles with
property taxes we don't have a big tax
base um we
provide as good at education as we can
with that tax base we don't have a lot
of extras we go through our deliber
deliberative session every year and have
a list of well we can afford this but
that's going to have to wait that's
going to have to wait you know we we
pinch every penny till ex
screams um so if this passed I could see
there would be a number of families in
Hudson who would love to be able to
transfer their students to Windam next
door because Windom and their
taxpayers
have invested in their school system and
been able to because they have a tax
base that is better able to support
lower class sizes investing in more
teachers and Par professionals investing
in a wider variety of programs at their
middle and high schools particularly the
middle and high school okay I love our
high school I love our middle school but
they offer more in Windom and I know
that many of our families in Hudson
would love to be able to just cross that
line not all of them would be able to
because we have students who have
discipline issues we have students who
have uh absenteeism issues we have
students with special needs who maybe
would try and go next door um we'd still
have to bear the cost of providing
services for
them we would still have to keep the
students with absentee issues with um
behavior issues uh discipline issues and
so I'm not sure our taxpayers would see
any relief of course we'd have to send
80% of the money we wouldn't have any
chance to negotiate that either that's
another imposition on local control
um because there'd be no negotiation
between us and Windam and I don't know
that the taxpayers of Windam would
want all of the students that would want
to come either yeah I understand the the
prime sponsor has said that the um local
school district is allowed to Define
capacity that's not made clear in this
bill um because it it just says Identify
capacity so you could also read it to
as is outlined in the minimum standards
for public schools that were just
adopted which is just a Flatout number
of you know certified adults to students
in the grade level across the building
um so that is unclear from the bill um
anyway Windam has invested in their
schools at a certain rate and I don't
know if they necessarily want an influx
of students either um I've been told
from you know professionals who work in
the wind School system that they're not
allowed to tuition their own students in
um their own children so I don't know
they want a lot of people coming from
another
town we we oppose this bill it's not
that's also not good because you can't
plan for the students who are going to
be in your class if you don't know who
they're going to be from month to month
you have a hard time making sure you
have the people to support their
academic needs the resources and
curriculum to support their academic
needs it's bad from so many perspectives
we would love to be able to support it
but you've got to fix it so that every
single school is able to offer the same
robust level of public education then we
can talk about you know helping with
Geographic uh transfers to better meet
whatever family's needs are and that's
my testimony thank you thank you any
questions represent muray thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I have a question about whether
or not through survey data you may have
compiled over the years do you have any
idea of of how many families might
experience an undue hardship maybe
having access to no car one car
multi-work parents uh and how they would
navigate transportation in this
circumstance I don't have any survey
data I know in my years of teaching we
had many families at my school in
nashaa who would have one car or no car
in the family it was a struggle to get
them to arrange for rides to get
families to parent teacher night I
worked in elementary school so we
usually have high attended to parent
teacher nights they want to come see the
projects they want to come meet the
teacher they they want to come enjoy a
snack um you know it's a good time
usually and we would feed feed uh the
family's dinner we would that was always
part of our parent teacher night um
there'd be a dinner in the cafeteria and
and all the uh displays and projects and
the kids would come and show off the
classroom and the projects so it was a
good positive things as well as talking
about you know how your kid is doing and
and and and and that part of it but we
would have our homeschool
coordinator um having to work
with people she knew that lived in the
neighborhood to get rid for some of our
families because you know this one's car
broke down that one didn't have a car
luckily I lived in Nashville some of
them would live you know close enough to
a bus line they could come but um last
few years buses don't run that late it
you know it's a problem um I don't have
hard data like I can't tell you what
percentage I just know it was something
that would
affect a number of families every year
and was always a chore that The
Homeschool coordinator had to arrange so
that the families could come participate
in their child education and and meet
and talk with us which they really want
to do and we really want to talk with
them can you imagine or or would you
envision that this might not just be an
urban issue it could also be a rural
issue for Rural access to Transportation
oh it's even worse if you're rural cuz
then you don't have the fall back of a
bus there's not that
option and you might not have neighbors
as close by that could maybe give you a
lift if you just you know walk down the
street yeah any other
questions pres of Hall thank you for
taking my question do you envision when
I'm thinking about the Hudson uh Windom
situation that a school district could
budget could contract with teachers they
they contracted their staff and all of a
sudden you have these people leaving now
they've got staff that they've hired
that they contracted but they they don't
need well that's say you might have way
more staff than you need and you've got
them for the year right um and then next
door they might not have enough staff or
if they're allowed to say well we're at
capacity you how does that work when
you're going month to month
um and that would be very difficult and
then again you don't know who's going to
be in your classroom from month to month
how do you meet the need learning needs
of those students so all of those things
are going through my head thank you yes
any other
questions saying none thank you
thanks Sarah
Scott thank you madam chair and members
of the committee for the opportunity to
testify here today my name is Sarah
Scott and I'm with Americans for
Prosperity here in New Hampshire uh I
think a lot of the points have already
been covered so I'll try to keep this
brief but uh I'm here today in support
of this legislation uh and I think
really this boils down to uh HB 741 is a
simple and yet transformative idea that
families have different needs and they
know what's best for their family while
many families are uh finding success in
their local public school there are
other families that are experiencing
certain needs that require them to look
outside of that District we've talked a
lot about academics and I think the
hearing in the Senate talked a lot about
academics also but there are a number of
situations that families might be facing
that would require them to look at
programs like this um so for example
Child Care is a huge issue in this state
um it's something that a number of young
families are facing here and allowing a
student to go to another District may be
their only solution for getting child
care so a lot of families are relying on
parents or uh family friends to go and
watch their children after school
if they're able to go and look at
another District where that family is
this might be the only real solution for
their family in terms of child care um
you have instances of families that the
parents work outside of the district
could be a teacher or somebody else that
you know 25 minute drive to school might
be the 25 minutes they get to spend with
their child every morning that really
leads to a lot of valuable family time
that because of work schedules they just
don't get any other way so um there
could be a number of situations with
family illness I know um my family for a
long time took care of a grandmother
that was not doing well and being able
to look at other districts and find
those opportunities there might be the
way that families are finding a solution
for aging family members so I think
there are a number of situations in
which this type of legislation would
provide huge benefits to the family um
there are a number of states that have
passed similar bills already uh I
believe the number is over 20 I've seen
conflicting reports over exactly how
many but I believe it's 25 um have
policies like this and have addressed a
number of the problems that have been
brought up today um so I don't think
this is uh an entirely new piece of
legislation I think many states have
figured out how to make this operate
efficiently and uh overall I would just
say I think this creates a great
opportunity for a lot of families here
and I hope you pass this legislation
thanks thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very
much and with that we'll close the
hearing on HB
e e